at the Tokyo Game Show there's more to
check out than just stuff on the show
floor I mean this is our chance to be in
Tokyo and to try on some of these
amazing arcade games we hear about all
the time and that's something that you
had and I got to do recently and one of
them was something that I hadn't heard
of before this is a Luigi's Mansion game
were you it had it like a literal vacuum
that you were holding while you played
the game yeah the game looked insane so
I basically used them the same mechanics
as the Luigi's Mansion game on the 30s
and GameCube well you have a flashlight
you use the stun ghosts and then you
suck them up and you need to pull them
into your vacuum and do these crazy
things inside a booth luckily you're in
a container so you don't knock anyone
out this is a very active game isn't it
well it's funny because there were it
was set up for two players but I imagine
that someone who had somebody went this
is a bad idea because when you're
playing there's only one vacuum in there
there must have been like horrendous
injuries that occurred when two people
are just swinging it back and forth but
that was me only give me we got to get
to play we also got to try out cook in
tournament which you know we've seen
it's been in Japanese arcades for a
while and it's gonna be coming to the US
but this is a game where you get to
fight as Pokemon and not just like
throwing them out there and saying hey
do battle you mean you physically
physically all the Pokemon so like they
were celebrating the new reveal of
Blaziken which was the new latest
character in pokken tournament and the
gameplays very similarly to a lot of the
anime fighting games so like you're in
naruto ultimate ninja storms and you're
DBZ Budda Budda guys it was like rising
thunder in that one button press has you
do a special move so you'll be moving
around in 3d space you know jumper
jumping around like doing grab news
doing stupid I don't say help a lot of
fun I really liked playing as Machamp
because he was a big grapple character
and just likes Pikachu into the ground
big G was also really fun because he
just like he was he looked really mad
all the time in a matte paper - he's
very cute so do you think this game
would be able to take the place of
Street Fighter in the arcade tournament
series I don't think it can it didn't
feel like I had as much nuance or depth
as like a straight but it and a lot of
the movie mechanics and hitboxes we're a
bit you know touch and go but that said
it's still a very fun game it had a card
system where you could actually save
your Pokemon data and train them up to
be magnificent fighters and I think when
it comes out of console it's something
that I that I
definitely want to play myself so we'll
be playing more of these arcade games
checking out stuff on the show floor and
just having fun while we're here in
Tokyo and stay tuned to game spot calm
for the latest on tokyo game show